Magic the Gathering is basically
football if you don't think about it.
Sitting around eating Cheetos, slinging
Commander is my biggest hobby. Closely
followed by sitting around eating
Cheetos and watching football. To be
honest, I usually call this soccer, but
my British friend Alex just built a
ridiculous Volron deck, and I don't want
him to target me any more than he
already does. Now, the deeper I dive
into both hobbies, the more I feel
they're connected. And not just by
Cheetos. They're actually similar in
many ways. from strategy to the
governing bodies. First and foremost,
strategy. Building a team or a deck is
half the battle. Every squad needs game
winners, enablers, and defenders that
protect your bottom line. And it's not
just about grabbing the flashiest or the
most expensive pieces. It's about
cohesion, balance, and clarity of
purpose. Take Paris on Jaman for
example, an ambitious football club
backed by Qatari Sports Washing Money.
But more on that later. In August 2021,
PSG shocked both the footballing world
and the world world by signing Lo Messi,
adding him to a lineup that already
included Neymar Jr. and Kilia Mbappe.
Now, on paper, this was the most
terrifying offensive trio imaginable,
aimed squarely at conquering Europe and
winning the Champions League. But, as
you might expect, things didn't go as
planned. While PSG had no trouble
tearing through the less competitive
domestic opponents, they struggled the
moment they faced truly balanced,
disciplined sides, and they actually
performed worse in the Champions League
than before the trio was assembled. This
parallels commander deck building
perfectly. Dropping money on the
flashiest stables can bring over-the-top
victories against certain opponents and
give the illusion that a deck is well
built. But the moment we face off
against a synergistic welloiled machine,
we will see that raw power alone doesn't
beat a practiced system. My favorite
football team is actually Atletico
Madrid from Spain. And I'm also quite
fun of Liverpool in the English Premier
League. The two clubs, in my opinion, do
share a certain philosophy in that they
don't chase the biggest stars, but
instead they build a system and bring in
role players with the exact profile they
need. With the right coaching and
strategy, they turn solid prospects into
elite performers. And that's exactly how
I wish to approach deck building in
commander. Passing up the quote unquote
best or the most expensive cards in
favor of role players that boost
consistency and coherence. And in the
long term, I hope to tune these decks to
outperform the stable studded ones. Next
up, winning, or rather not winning. If
you know anything about my team,
Atletico Madrid, you will know what I'm
talking about. They're not the
winningest team, not even close.
Domestically, they're flanked by two of
the biggest clubs in the world, Real
Madrid and Barcelona. In Europe, it's
been heartbreak after heartbreak, coming
within seconds of lifting the Ultimate
Trophy, only to fall short. But here's
the thing, most teams don't win. I mean,
the Spanish League has 20 teams, only
one champion each year. The Champions
League, 36 contenders, and just one
takes it home at the end. Losing is the
norm, winning is the exception. But does
not lifting a trophy make everything
else meaningless? I mean the fans keep
coming back game after game. They
celebrate every goal and every hard
thought win because those moments
matter. And in commander winning is also
not a common occurrence or at least it
shouldn't be. There are four players and
one remains standing at the end. So we
have to appreciate and enjoy the rest of
the experience. When a carefully crafted
synergy unfolds just as planned. When we
pull off a clever two for one. when the
deck we've spent hours fine-tuning does
exactly what it was built to do. These
are signs that the engine is running,
that our ideas work. In games as complex
and chaotic as football or commander,
luck will always be a factor. We do live
in a world where the winner takes all,
but that doesn't mean the ones that
don't win need to walk away
empty-handed. Number three, speaking of
luck, there's plenty of it in both
games. The football is round and so are
most Magic players. It's not over till
it's over. In both games, you play to
your outs. And honestly, the only thing
more satisfying than snatching victory
from the jaws of defeat is watching your
friend do the opposite. Back in 2013
Magic World Championship finals, Shahar
Shanhar found himself staring down Reed
Duke in what he later described as a 95
to5 matchup against him. But somehow he
turned it around and took home the
trophy in a miraculous fashion. In the
postgame interview, something he said
stuck with me.
>> I was like, "Yeah, I mean, but we have a
plan. we'll follow through and we'll
hope for the best and like you know the
plan is to play like Vindelink click
restoration angel
>> blanket take u you know fog a little bit
and then crypto command snap caster mage
cryptic command and that's exactly what
happened that was the plan that exactly
what happened
>> and I saw that mindset again recently in
a completely different arena just a few
days ago actually concluded the 2025
FIFA Club World Cup finals
New Jersey of all places and Paris
Sanjgeran had changed their philosophy,
moving away from building around stars
and instead crafting a wellbalanced,
cohesive unit. And it worked. They
steamrolled their way through Europe,
even handing Inter Milan a historic
defeat in the Champions League final.
Many called this PSG team one of the
most dominant in modern football
history. And in the final of the club
World Cup, they were expected to do the
same to Chelsea, a club with legacy, but
going through years of inconsistency and
chaos. The memes were already flying.
PSG was supposed to walk it, but Chelsea
wasn't reading the script. I stayed up
and watched the game, and from the first
minute, PSG found themselves strangled
for space. Chelsea targeted their left
flank, overloaded it, and before you
know it, the goals came. And it wasn't
long before it hit everyone. Chelsea was
the better team that day. Calling them
an underdog might sound silly. This is
Chelsea after all, but make no mistake,
they were. and they showed up hungry and
somehow caught their opponents on an off
day. So, what's the takeaway? Have a
plan. Play to your outs. In Commander,
that lesson hits even harder than in
football or 60card [music] formats
because multiplayer adds chaos and
variance. Too often, we look at a board
state and just give up. We think it's
over. No chance. But we're only seeing a
small part of the picture. We don't know
what's in our opponent's hands, what
tricks they're hiding in their decks,
and more importantly, what's going on in
their minds. In football, when you're
two goals down in the 89th minute, it's
probably over. But in commander,
everything can change with just one
spell, one gamebreaking top deck, or one
opponent turning on another. It's not
just about having else. It's about being
ready to see them when they show up. And
when they do, that's how you turn defeat
into the kind of victory you never
forget. Number four, pace. Football and
Magic are of a similar pace. Now, I know
that sounds ridiculous, but there's been
reports showing decline in football's
popularity for younger audience
nowadays. In the era of Tik Tok and
short videos, football just doesn't
provide satisfaction and stimulation at
a high enough frequency for most to want
to stick around. To be fair, football or
watching it on TV at least can be
boring. Imagine trying to get a friend
into it and the first game you watch
together ends up a stalemate. No, no.
And even if they end up scoring a goal
or two is often 20, 30 minutes, or even
an hour of buildup, to actually enjoy
the sport, you need to invest time into
it first to understand the intricate
plays and tactics [music]
so that it's something to watch, even
without goals. Research shows that Gen Z
audiences heavily favor esports over
traditional ones, and those that do
watch football often do it through
highlights. And from this, you can see
why the football demographic is starting
to look like an Asian population
pyramid. Meanwhile, Magic, especially
Commander, falls into a similar space. I
often ask myself why I keep coming back
to this game. Video games are just so
much more efficient. Imagine playing a
game where every 5 minutes of action
leads to 10 to 15 minutes of load
screen. That's what Commander feels like
sometimes. So, why do we play it? I
guess it's the chatting banters. Well,
we get a breathing room to study the
board, savor the tension, and get lost
in the unfolding story of the game. And
just like football, I guess this is why
I enjoy both hobbies. When you take the
time to build up to be fully invested in
the narrative, the payoff is that much
more satisfying. And I feel this is
something lost on much of the younger
generation. Not to mention the friends
we make along the way. Number five, the
rules. At this point, I'm over 10 years
into both hobbies, and I feel like I
still don't understand their rules at
all. For football, it's the
inconsistency. How is this a handball
when this is not? And how is this a red
card while this is just a warning and I
learn new rules with almost every
tournament I watch and sometimes it
feels like they're just making it up
along the way. Now for Magic is a little
different. Things are consistent for the
most part, but sometimes I feel just as
lost. I got my first judge certificate
10 years ago, but to this day I still
shiver at the mention of layers and time
stamp. Now it's all fun in games until
we talk about money. Number six, the
governing body or governing bodies in
football's case. They're all greedy and
blatantly pursuing profit over anything
else. I'm sure this comes to a surprise
to no one, but everything is driven by
money, and stakeholders on both ends
have been put into a frog in boiling
water situation for years, if not
decades. For Magic, what used to be a
game driven by community, creativity,
and card singing fun has gradually
shifted into a corporate content
pipeline. Catering their decisions to
the biggest spenders and no one else.
They're adjusting the pace just right
for most players to feel the heat
turning up, but not enough to jump out
of the pot. And before you know it, we
have crossover sets costing $230 per
boxing standard and $200 for a set of
staples. Meanwhile, in the footballing
world, the governing bodies FIFA and
UEFA have been ramping up the number of
games being played each year, especially
by the biggest teams, constantly adding
new tournaments and expanding existing
ones for more sponsorships. Take the
Club World Cup held in the US as an
example. They took a mini friendly
tournament and expanded it to 32 teams,
each playing three to seven games,
depending on how deep they go in the
tournament. This may not sound like
much, but considering how congested
their regular seasons already are, this
may very well be the last draw. The
tournament was held in America against
the extreme heat and severe weather.
Plenty of players and coaches have
spoken out about the absurdity, but
nothing will change. We are already
seeing an increased frequency in player
injuries from minor to terrifying. Not
to mention the lack of concrete research
on the potential long-term impact of
this kind of intensity on a player's
well-being postretirement. But football
actually took it one step further than
Hasbro ever would hopefully. Sports
washing. Statebacked conglomerates and
billionaires are backing clubs to clean
up their image. Takeovers like
Manchester City and the aforementioned
PSG aren't about passion. They're about
laundering reputations. The World Cup in
Qatar wasn't a celebration of the sport.
It was a $220 billion PR stunt built on
migrant workers suffering. Leagues now
ban rules for financial doping and fans
are left watching a sanitized product.
None of that matters. We go where the
money leads. And this brings us to the
last point. Seven. Our principles
eventually succumb to entertainment. The
footballing world is never lacking in
controversies. As legendary coach Jose
Mourinho once remarked, "Don't idolize
footballers. Some of them are pure
trash."
From an organizational level, teams and
even tournaments are being backed by
entities with atrocious human rights
violations. And there are certain new
players that should be rotting in jail
rather than enjoying the eminence of a
sports star. People are mostly aware and
some may genuinely be up in arms about
it. They care, but it never lasts. At
the end of the day, outrage fades, but
sponsors keep paying. And for a vast
majority of fans, it's difficult to not
tune in when a big game is on. Whether
it's Manchester City versus PSG, or in
its reality, Saudi Arabia versus Qatar.
Sounds familiar. While Magic is
fortunate that we don't have nearly as
heavy a moral burden, we can see that
action speaks louder than words of
[music] protest. Players will criticize
Hasbro's greed, yelling, "The game is
dead and swear off buying product until
the next universe is beyond." Then the
discourse phase, the sales charts
explode, and the cycle resets. The
lesson is clear in football and magic.
Killing the game is lucrative, and the
decision makers at the top know us,
their consumers, better than we know
ourselves. Ending this on a rather
negative note, aren't we? But despite
all that, me and so many other players
are still deep into this mess. Some even
making YouTube channels promoting the
company with so many questionable
practices. Why addiction? I mean sunk
cost. I mean lack of social skill. I
mean the community is the best part.
Yes, there you go. At the end of the
day, both EDH and football are more than
just games. They're about belonging. You
come in for the place, the decks, the
goals, but you stay for the people.
Football fans gather in pubs, yell at
the screen together, live and die with
their teams. We wear the same colors,
chant the same chance. Even rivals
respect each other because we all get
it. Commander is the same. You might
start as strangers at a table, but after
3 4 hours of deals, betrayal, and bad
beats, and brilliant top decks, you're
not strangers anymore. You laugh about
the same moments. You talk about that
one card that completely changed the
game. And when the game's over, you want
to sit down and do it all over again.
Not because you won, but because it was
fun with them. And this is why football
is magic. Thanks for coming to my TED
talk.
Subscribe. Subscribe. Subscribe.
Subscribe.